hey guys I'm Jess this is Dan who's
returned from being sick and we're here
to tell you about all the news things
that happen today so stick around let's
start you guys off with a blast from the
past
it says they're releasing a full out for
game of the Year Edition as well as some
of those highly sought after Pitt boys
the game of the Year Edition comes with
the base game along with all six of the
games DLC expansions which I will now
list for you Nuka world volt tech
workshop contraptions workshop far
harbour wasteland workshop and
automatron fallout for game of the year
edition will launch on September 26 460
caps if you cast your mind back to 2015
you'll probably remember that the NES
classic of that year was the fallout for
pip-boy edition the special edition came
with the game and a fancy life-sized
pip-boy wearable that she could slot
your phone into if you were one of the
many people who stayed up far too late
trying to snag one when they went up for
pre-order only to be disappointed I've
got good news
Bethesda is releasing a limited number
to be sold at select North American
retailers it's unclear exactly which
retailers but we do know that it'll set
you back a hundred bucks come backed
with the Goudy Edition and we'll launch
the same day as the standalone Goudy
edition on September 26th if you're an
achievement hunter on Xbox you'll
probably want to know that the
achievement system is fundamentally
changing not to worry though I'm sure
you guys will figure out a way to gain
the system soon enough your Xbox gamer
score is designed so you can compare
yourself to other people and potentially
feel bad about yourself you know like
Facebook the problem is though for
players who might play just a few titles
a lot of the time it doesn't necessarily
reflect their level of skill or the
amount of time they've put in
considering that Xbox corporate vice
president Mike Ibarra told Windows
central that the publisher is working
toward something that fundamentally
changes its approach to achievements he
dropped the example of a halo 5 pro who
may only have a game a score of 2,000
saying they want to find a way to
celebrate that person and let people
show up and represent their gaming
history and the type of gamer they are
the thing about playing overwatch with a
cold is now I have an excuse for my ever
slipping standing and competitive play
well since we're talking about overwatch
it's worth mentioning that death matches
are on their way to
shooter deathmatches will function
exactly as it says on the tin tames our
individuals attempt to kill each other
for points the free-for-all flavor for
all you lone wolves out there will end
when the first player scores 20 kills
and if you're more of a team deathmatch
player your kill limit will be 30 if
you're worried that the existing maps
don't really lend themselves to the new
mode not to worry
Blizzard is releasing a purpose-built
map Chateau kill yet as well as tweaking
existing maps to better support the new
mode if you have overwatch on PC you can
give deathmatch a try on the public test
realm it's unclear when the new mode and
map will be coming to other platforms
but traditionally you'll only need to
wait a few weeks
don't fret though we'll be sure to let
you know once it's available that's all
we have for you today and don't forget
to tune in tomorrow for our top 5
stories of the entire week do you let us
know down in that comment section what
you thought today starts and what funny
thing you think Jen will do in his
sickness haze tomorrow
[Music]
well that's quiet definitely need the
wrong we definitely definitely need the
rock woman's yawn